it has been a wild 24 hours of news we
will talk about the Tucker Carlson
firing the Don Lemon firing we will look
at new interviews from Ron DeSantis and
Donald Trump showing what a very ugly
2024 Republican primary might look like
but the big news Joe Biden announcing
that he is indeed running for
re-election in 2024
if he were to win he would best his own
record of the oldest age to start a
presidential term remember that Joe
Biden already the oldest president ever
to start a presidential term at 78 when
he was inaugurated in January of 2021
second would of course be Ronald Reagan
at age 73 Joe Biden would be 82 I
believe if my math is right and my
recollection and my facts at the start
of a second term but can he get there
well that is of course a different
question the New York Times headline
today Biden announces re-election bid
defying Trump and history while the
president once pitched himself as a
bridge to a new generation of democratic
leaders he has decided that he is not
ready to turn the torch over yet there
may be
an event sometime later this week of
with another announcement but for now
this is the announcement and there is
all sorts of speculation that honestly I
will mention but I don't think is that
useful to just really dwell on
everything from
Biden doesn't really plan to stay all
the way to the election this is a
placeholder because it would hurt him to
say now that he's not running for
reelection but he has to say something
because Trump's running and DeSantis
might soon be getting in and he can't
just do nothing but he's going to be a
placeholder for the eventual nominee
when Biden bows out well we have no
evidence that that's the plan of course
you can always assert that someone is
lying and they have some real plan
behind the scenes but we don't have
evidence of that right now much of this
is driven I think by two things Joe
Biden's age and again the fact that he
once did Pitch himself as a bridge as a
transitional president who might only
serve for one term if any of those
scenarios happen we are going to have
time to discuss and to analyze but it
doesn't seem very worthwhile to invest
time in that right now now what I think
is more interesting to look at is where
are the polls today and do Democrats
want Biden to run let's start with
polling there is a a plethora of polling
hypothetical polling which says if it's
Biden versus DeSantis or if it's Biden
versus Trump what are people saying
right now a new poll released today from
ipsos Reuters has Biden ahead of
DeSantis by nine
and Biden ahead of Trump by five this
poll is out of step with other polling
in two ways number one in most polling
Biden does better against Trump than
DeSantis in this poll Biden does better
against DeSantis it's also different
um in that the numbers are are you know
if you look at most of these other polls
we're talking about tied all the way up
to like plus four plus five and plus
nine is not something that we are seeing
we similarly have another poll released
two days ago for morning consult which
has Biden plus four over DeSantis and
plus one over Trump
and then a number of other polls in
which Biden does better against Trump
than DeSantis but the early numbers and
they are worth a little bit but not that
much right now are that Joe Biden for
the most part is polling ahead of the
two most likely Republican uh
challengers in 2024. this gets us to the
third component of this discussion which
is are voters happy with the most likely
choices which are Biden and Trump and
the answer is no not really and we
talked about this yesterday on the bonus
show a little bit oh the bonus show
where you want to make money sure
everybody else that makes money to find
themselves is bad yeah we made money
yesterday on the bonus show talking
about this majorities don't want Biden
and Trump to run in 2024. a new NBC News
poll found that 60 of Americans think
Trump should not try to retake the Oval
Office including roughly a third of
Republicans at the same time 70 percent
of them Americans think Biden shouldn't
seek a second term including 51 percent
of Democrats a majority of Democrats
don't believe Biden would seek a second
term now what we spoke about yesterday
with producer pat on the bonus show is
just because you would rather a
different Choice doesn't mean if you're
a Democrat you're going to vote for
Trump or if you're a republican you're
going to vote for Biden it doesn't mean
that and I do think that all of the data
points us to if these are the choices
even if you'd rather someone else if
you're not a trump person you're not
going to vote for Trump just because
you'd rather someone other than Biden
and vice versa now I want to go one step
further you all know
I've not been a Biden cheerleader I
don't find Biden electrifying or
exciting or any of it but I try to
evaluate presidencies
as objectively as possible
and I'm going to have a deeper dive on
this for you soon when I look on paper
as the kids say
it's hard to argue that the Biden
presidency
is anything but one of the most
successful presidential terms in a very
long time I know I know Biden is not as
left as I would like and Biden was not
the guy I supported in the primary and
all these different things but when you
actually look at accomplishments
particularly in the context in which Joe
Biden is serving this first of
potentially two terms
it is really difficult to say that this
is not a very successful presidential
term it's crazy to think about I will
lay it out for you as a non-biden
cheerleader just looking to be as
objective as possible maybe we'll do
that tomorrow or Thursday maybe we'll
give it a little more time uh and look
at that next week but Joe Biden running
for reelection we are going to be
watching this election very closely we
really are you know we have this coupon
code 24 starts now on our website
we really are in the midst of the 2024
election as quickly it feels like we're
still uh seeing Trump at 2 A.M the day
after the 2020 election
saying I guess I won
uh feels like it was just yesterday but
we really are ramping up here in the
2024 election and we're going to be
covering all of it for you we've talked
on the show about how internet service
providers have been logging everything
their customers do online and selling
that data tech companies use trackers in
websites and apps to collect your data
you can Shield yourself from all of it
by using a VPN every time you connect to
the internet the VPN I use is private
internet access it's the only VPN that
has proven multiple times in court they
do not log your activity our sponsor
private internet access hides my IP
address prevents big Tech from being
able to paint a picture of who I am and
what I do online and it works for all of
your favorite streaming platforms like
Netflix and Hulu to access shows and
movies normally only available in other
countries it's one of the only vpns that
works for peer-to-peer file sharing and
the best part is you can protect
unlimited devices with just one account
going online without private internet
access is like leaving your phone
unattended in a crowded room anyone can
just take a glance my audience gets 83
percent off that's just 203 a month plus
four extra months for free go to
piavpn.com Pacman the link is down below